[Music]
hey everybody welcome once again to
tomes of terror my little book review
series that i do on here so
arkansas-based author uh robert campbell
was nice enough to contact me several
weeks ago and ask if i wanted to receive
a signed copy of what i'm assuming is
his first novel uh for review and of
course you know i readily agreed because
that's a very nice thing to do so thank
you very much robert uh he actually went
to great personal expense to send it to
me by one day shipping
so i really do appreciate it and like i
said if you're an author as well and you
want to send me a book or send me a link
to your book if it's on kindle unlimited
or something like that
to review then i will uh make every
effort to do that although sometimes it
might be a few weeks because i usually
have uh you know stuff i have reviews
like kind of scheduled about a month in
advance
so the book in question is this one
the legend of the cove witch i'm sorry
there's like kind of a glare on there
but yeah you can see that okay uh so
evidently like according to the endnote
like at the end of the book where it
says the end and then it has the date
like because you know a lot of authors
do that
so evidently this was finished in 2016
and also also the author's note at the
beginning said that this was the third
draft of the book and the one that he
was the happiest with um but the
publication date on google books is
listed as october 2021 so i'm assuming
that he you know took that time to get
it all together or whatever now speaking
of google books this is a little bit
weird
this novel's entry on there uh features
the bio of another writer named robert
campbell who is actually an 85 year old
architect who graduated from harvard
like a long time ago and currently
writes about architecture like he's an
architecture critic for the boston globe
so
that's not the same guy um the guy that
wrote this like appears at least from
his photo like much much younger so yeah
i think that's really weird that's
probably just happened because robert
campbell like the old guy has a
wikipedia page so google just pulled it
off of there i'm assuming uh so just a
heads up if you go to google books
and see this book's entry on there uh
that's actually not the actual bio of
the guy that actually wrote this book so
i just thought i would uh point that out
now this novel i don't believe it
specifically states anywhere that it's y
a uh or that it's targeted toward a
younger audience but when i started
reading it that was like the impression
that i got and robert campbell uh does
have children's author featured quite
prominently in his actual bio like the
real one so i'm going to assume that
this was written for a younger audience
although i will say that it does have
some fairly graphic violence and uh some
a couple of really brief not terribly
graphic uh sex scenes like i said i'm
not real
familiar with what's out there in y a so
i don't know what the standards are like
as far as violence or sex or whatever
goes so this might be par for the course
not entirely sure so the beginning of
the story is set in the present day in
uh the author's hometown so it's a real
place called magnet cove arkansas
and the story revolves around a high
school student named noella mclean
and she's at the start of the story busy
doing what most teenage girls do i guess
uh hanging out with her best friend
whose name is brandy working on class
assignments you know doing school [ __ ]
and also crushing on the hot quarterback
at school whose name is nicholas happily
uh nicholas also returns her affections
so you know that's cool he even asked
her to the homecoming dance and she just
squeezed with excitement noelle is over
the moon she's like uh my life couldn't
get any better than this and since this
is a horror novel you know that that's
not gonna last so yeah so soon after
that though uh you know a sort of darker
paul i guess is cast over the teenager's
life
so one night she has this really vivid
nightmare
in which a distant ancestor of hers
whose name is jeanette mclean
pursues her through this like old
village which is a village i guess like
in local lore is one that is supposedly
is like this old village from the 17th
century i think and
you know they they talk about it being
out there but no one's ever found it so
it's sort of like they think it's really
there but it's like mythical because
nobody ever knew exactly where it was
so she gets pursued through this village
and is obviously very scary and she gets
rescued by this ghostly little girl
whose name is abigail
now abigail
warns noella that jeanette who is the
fabled cove witch and also little
abigail's mother i believe abigail is
about six years old if i'm remembering
correctly that jeanette is going to be
coming and killing noella very soon
and like i said this is a dream
so noella just like everybody else
presumably in this uh town has heard all
these legends about the cove witch
and particularly the story that jeanette
maclean you know the titular kov witch
is said to reappear every generation and
murder one of her ancestors
as revenge for what had been done to her
like centuries ago
apparently nobody in magnet cove really
believes in the cove witch anymore but
noella is kind of starting to have her
doubts you know yes she has the
nightmare but then she's at the movies
with her friends and she has this other
vision of jeanette
where she thinks like the witch is like
coming together and like grabs her arm
and after she wakes up from this
encounter
it actually actually has like a
hand-shaped like bruise on her arm or
whatever so she's like okay well this
[ __ ] is probably real so it so happens
that shortly after this incident one of
the teachers at school
assigns a research paper i think like
about a historical figure or something
like that and she insists that noella
write one about jeanette maclean because
they're like hey that's your distant
ancestor so wouldn't it be neat if you
wrote like a paper about her and about
the legend that's brought up about her
and stuff like that now noella uh
because she's had all this like creepy
[ __ ] start happening she's pretty
reluctant to do this especially since
she's starting to suspect that the kov
witch actually might be real and
actually might be coming to get her for
whatever reason
but she can't really manage to talk her
way out of it
so
her and her friends decide that they're
gonna go visit noella's aunt neddy who i
think um at least according to the
author's note at the beginning of the
book is based on a real person so i'm
thinking that it's probably like the
author's aunt or something like that
because i think her name was neddy as
well uh he thanked her in the author's
night at the beginning so i'm assuming
this is based on a real uh relative of
his
so nettie seems like she's something
like the family historian like she has
like all of these things um like
journals and you know documents and
stuff like that like from all their
distant relations so she has all that
stuff
and stuff about that and stuff about
like the curse it's because supposedly
that this family is uh cursed like i
said the witch is supposed to come like
once every generation and kill one of
the relatives
now from that point forward
uh the novel takes place pretty much
entirely in the past
as noella and her friends are basically
it's kind of like a frame story like the
modern day stuff like then it goes back
to the past and so they're essentially
like listening to nettie like laying out
all of this stuff like from the ancestor
journals and the documents and things
like that
so we first go back to 1691
and learn how jeannette who started out
as this really beautiful very decent
very pure-hearted young woman
eventually ends up like turning to the
dark side uh due to a combination of
this magic amulet called the raven's eye
that her husband gerard gives her like
for christmas one year
um and
sort of like her uncontained fury at
this man well at first it's just like
one man but like a guy named magistrate
coleman who is kind of like witch finder
general [ __ ] where he's just
kind of like he's been burning innocent
girls like his witches left and right um
even though i think in this i mean
obviously in this book's universe which
is actually do exist so
i don't know if it's implied that some
of the people that he burned like were
actually witches so [ __ ] them but it's
like you know what i mean but uh you
know but some of the girls were
obviously innocent and he's getting a
little too uh heavy-handed with the
witch burning and jeanette doesn't like
it
and uh so she decides to take revenge on
him and that's kind of what is the
catalyst for her like turning evil or
like turning to the dark side and also
kind of like her lust for power like
that comes from this amulet which
essentially the amulet
it kind of does a thing where
well it also has to do with there's this
tree it's like kind of like a magical
tree it's probably like a nematone or
nematode i'm not sure how you pronounce
it um but it kind of grows out in the
forest and she gets like a lot of her
power from that but essentially like if
you say this latin phrase like whatever
you want to happen like the amulet will
kind of like make it happen so you can i
mean you i guess you kind of have to
like learn how to do it and [ __ ] like
that but but you can use you don't have
to use it for evil though like the
amulet like it could go either way it's
just like a magical device like how you
use it is up to you kind of thing
so uh so initially at first i mean
jeanette uses her emulate for good you
know what i mean just like helping
people around the town or whatever but
eventually because she's mad at
magistrate coleman and then she starts
getting mad at other people in the town
and starts thinking oh it wouldn't hurt
to just like [ __ ] up this person because
they're a douche or whatever and
then as that starts going on um
something comes up where you know and
like i said i don't want to spoil like
the plot points and stuff but um she
feels like there's kind of like a
personal betrayal like by her family so
she gets so mad that she essentially
like ends up murdering like a whole
bunch of the townsfolk like in various
horrible ways including her daughter
abigail who was six years old that that
was kind of accidentally on purpose kind
of like that i don't think she actually
meant to kill her daughter but it kind
of ended up like that because she was
like raging out or whatever so as the
story goes on we jump ahead a bit like
that's kind of the bulk of it and then
like there's sort of like a shorter
uh section at the end
which kind of like jumps ahead like to
successive generations and like what
happened
in those generations so it goes a little
bit into you know this family was doing
this and they're this relative and then
the witch came during this circumstance
and [ __ ] up this person and whatever
um and then in between there's like
little interludes like where we come
back to the present with noella and the
gang and
there's basically just a page where
they're just kind of like oh man that
was [ __ ] up or whatever and then like
we go back to the past again so like i
said it's essentially like a frame story
almost all of it well i don't know if
almost all of it but
a good portion of the book like takes
place in the past most of it in 1691 but
then it skips ahead and then like the
very beginning and the very end
are set in the modern day so like at the
end of the story because you kind of
knew that it was building up to this
because you've seen like the witch like
appearing in every generation and
obviously she's going to appear in this
generation and go after noella so she
has to figure out
some way to destroy the witch which
nobody has been able to do thus far
because she's really powerful and sort
of like end of the family curse forever
so she has to figure out like what to do
that you know other people haven't
figured out so far now i will say um i
love stories about witches uh i love
stories about intergenerational curses
uh so when both of those things are are
cooking like i really really like that
kind of thing but i will say the i think
the main thing that let this novel down
was not so much the story which i
thought was like actually really
interesting and really well thought out
and you know it was like a good idea
like i said i love which stuff but i
think it was mostly like the execution
now according to the author's
acknowledgment at the beginning of the
book uh the novel did have an editor but
it doesn't i mean
and i hate saying this but it's like it
really seems like it didn't because
the the book has a lot a lot of like
formatting and grammatical errors
now the most common of these were
uh run-on sentences and sentence
fragments and that's crazy because i
feel like the book i talked about last
week the house on rectory lane that had
a lot of run-on sentences too what is
that
are we doing that now because i thought
like that's yeah you're not supposed to
do run-on sentences but uh but yeah so
i've seen that a lot like in books
recently and i've just decided if
everybody just said [ __ ] it and it's
like we're just gonna we're just gonna
have senses like who needs periods or
semicolons we're just gonna put comma in
there but yeah so because the yeah house
of rectory lane was like that too
uh so yeah so that was the most common
thing was run on sentences sentence
fragments there were also and this is
another thing that happened in house on
rectory lane was that there were a lot
of missing
dialogue quotes so you couldn't tell
when the person stopped talking and when
it went back to just you know exposition
or whatever
and also another thing that house on
rectory lane did was that sometimes two
or more characters would be talking in
the same paragraph which is usually
something you don't do because it's too
confusing
because you know usually if a new
character is talking you move to another
paragraph because you know then you know
this is a different person talking when
there's a couple different people's
quotes in there i it sounds like it's
the same person talking so is that so it
was kind of confusing also there was
kind of like
real kind of like um
mistakes have would have been like easy
to fix like incorrect usage of t o t you
know two like t o t o o a lot of
incorrect uses of those of and off your
y o u r and your y o u apostrophe r e so
there was like a lot of uh messes and
that was a lot messed up uh things of
that nature so like i said i hate saying
this kind of stuff i don't like to come
down too hard on independently published
authors um because i'm one myself and i
know how hard it is that you can't i
mean you know us broke asses can't
really afford to hire like a
professional editor so like go through
stuff but so so i'm willing to give like
a lot of latitude like if it's not too
egregious but this one really really had
like a lot and i kind of feel like the
editor probably should have caught them
because it really did like kind of
interfere with your enjoyment of the
story which is actually very good i will
say too that there was kind of like
i don't want to say
i don't know like the the tone of the
writing seemed like it was a little bit
like repetitive it seemed like kind of a
little bit
maybe amateurish and maybe that was
because like i said that's kind of why i
got the idea that it was you know geared
toward like a younger audience
but
one thing i noticed that happened like a
bunch of times uh was that there'd be
there'd be a scene where like something
happened like the witch appeared and
like killed somebody or something like
that and then like the next scene or the
scene after that would be somebody
running to a house and saying oh my god
like the witch killed somebody and then
they would describe it so it was almost
kind of like
you're repeating the same scene over
over again except this time it happened
and then you were telling somebody about
it so
i kind of feel like that just probably
just needed to be trimmed out because
you don't really have to it's like you
know we already saw that happen we don't
need to see somebody like telling
somebody that happened or you can like
shorten that a little bit because like i
said it's it's just kind of like
unnecessary uh it would have made the
plot flow a lot better if some of that
was trimmed out also some of the
dialogue didn't sound all that realistic
sounded a little bit uh stilted
and
i will say this is something that kind
of stood out to me too like in the
sections of the book that were set in
the past
there were some kind of like
anachronistic
phrases and concepts used like sometimes
like a character who was supposedly like
in 1691
would be like what's the deal dad or
something like that you know what i mean
whereas like somebody in 1691 i'm
presuming like i didn't live back then i
don't know but uh but probably wouldn't
say that and so it was kind of like
brought you out of the story a little
bit also here's another weird thing
there were several references in the
book
to like gravestones and buildings and
stuff like that being damaged by acid
rain
and
i was like maybe i don't know i'm not
like a climate scientist or anything
like that but it wasn't acid rain wasn't
really a thing until like the 1970s
right that was just because of like
industrialization and like too much
chemicals being pumped in the atmosphere
and causing acid rain i thought that was
like a 1970s thing i didn't think it
would have been a thing in the 17th
century i mean i don't know like like i
said i don't know but it was just like
weird that it kept coming up also i
noticed a scene and i could be totally
off on this too but like just from my
understanding okay so there was a scene
where the characters in
1691 i think it was in the 1691 section
were celebrating christmas but they were
celebrating it very much the way modern
people would celebrate it which i'm
pretty sure they didn't do in the 17th
century i mean the puritans
actually outlawed christmas because of
its pagan association so you'd kind of
if you wanted to sell like people did
celebrate it but they kind of had to
keep it on the dl a little bit because
the puritans were like no no we don't
like any of that kind of stuff and it
wasn't really christmas back then wasn't
really like a child-focused gift-giving
kind of holiday it was more kind of like
let's get drunk and eat a lot kind of
holiday which i guess it kind of is but
they didn't really have the whole like
oh kid-focused
gift-giving thing really until like the
19th century it was more just kind of
like a it was more like an adult focus
like bacchanal type of holiday uh which
is why the parents didn't like it
because they're like having fun we can't
have that like with all the drinking of
food and stuff so i don't think that the
characters
were puritans necessarily but had they
been like the puritans absolutely did
not celebrate christmas uh you know that
that was kind of one of the things
and you know so that was something that
just stood out to me like i said it
could have been i could have been way
off because colonial america was kind of
like all over the place with how they
celebrated things people did celebrate
christmas back then i'm not saying that
but the puritans for sure did not um and
like i said it wasn't celebrated
anything like we celebrate it nowadays
really other than like the feasting and
the excessive drinking which is mostly
what it was uh so there was that so that
was another thing that kind of like
brought me out of the story a little bit
because it was supposed to be in the
past and it was kind of like bringing me
up to the modern day because it sounded
too modern so i will say like overall
you know there is absolutely an awesome
story in here and i really really liked
i love stories about witches like i said
i really really like stories about
family curses i love that kind of [ __ ]
and i really really liked the idea
of jeanette the cove witch being this
really like saintly
uh gracious woman who everybody loved
and then
you know her getting the amulet and then
her as it goes on like perceiving
that
people in the village had wronged her or
wronged others like she was calm is
trying to like justify it by saying she
was trying to protect others but then it
got to a point where she was like into
like she liked like [ __ ] up other
people and so she you know it was like a
heel turn essentially like she was this
wonderful person but
this amulet was maybe kind of i don't
know i kind of got the feeling that
maybe the amulet even though you could
use it for either good or evil i almost
kind of like got the feeling that it was
kind of like the ring of power you know
i mean like from lord of the rings where
if you had it like it was just um you
know the the temptation to like [ __ ]
people up was just too great if you were
like that kind of person and it took
like a really saintly person to not do
that and uh you know even though she
seemed very saintly
you know it still got the better of her
like because at first she thought she
was protecting people and then people
came after her and they came after her
sister and she thought she was
protecting your sister and so she's like
well i'm gonna [ __ ] up all these people
like to do and then like she just got
more and more evil like as time went on
so i really liked that i will say i one
complaint i will say about that is i
think that she like the heel turn was
like too quick like she turned evil too
fast i kind of which wish it would have
been more of like a gradual
downfall instead of oh i'll do a couple
good things and then yeah [ __ ] this i'm
going to blow their heads up first i
don't think she didn't blow anybody's
that up but you know what i mean so uh
so yeah so i thought that was a little
bit too fast but i liked that
i liked that being the core of the story
you know what i mean so i really think
there's like a really good story here
and i really think the only thing that
lets it down
is the editing i really kind of feel
like this needed a better editor uh to
clean up you know all the run-on
sentences all the sentence fragments
clean up all the quotes like move the
quotes uh you know where they're
supposed to be like to other paragraphs
and stuff like that so it's more clear
like what's going on like i said maybe
edit out some of the stuff where the
characters are telling people what just
happened because you know we already saw
what just happened so we don't need to
see it again so there's that kind of
thing so i'm just saying like like i
said
i really do appreciate uh robert
campbell you sending me this uh book i
really did have a good time reading it i
really do like uh the witch thing and
everything like that uh but yeah so
that'll do it for this tomes of terror
and i will see you guys on the next one
bye